hey David what would be your biggest
criticism of the left in America this is
a great question and I addressed this a
little bit on the Joe Rogan program I
addressed this a little bit on the
Monday show this week in talking about
these groups that have cropped up like
for example progressives against David
Pakman and Sam cedar as many of you
probably know I am against toxic
identity politics but I don't think
toxic identity politics is as big of an
issue on the left as some think it is
when I see identity politics used as a
cudgel I called it out but mostly my
view on identity politics is we all
should have a say and we should be aware
that people whose identity relates to
the issue at hand in some particular way
might have valuable insight which we
should listen to Wow hugely
controversial right but that's my view
when it comes to SJW whatever right I
mean okay there are people who in any
movement can take things too far but
big-picture sjw's are not the problem on
the Left ante feh okay to the extent an
Tifa has been violent I'm against it but
antifa
is very small and it is not
representative of the left's issues in
any kind of big picture sense so what I
do think is a problem on the left that
worries me is the too rigid definition
of what is acceptable within the left at
this point in time I'm not going to redo
this entire commentary because I did it
on Monday but there's a really good
article in Politico by Joshua sites
called progressives should read
progressive history so that they don't
blow it this time when you go back to
the progressive movement of the early
1900s when you go to the New Deal era of
the 30s and you see the huge successes
that progressives accomplished when you
look at conservatives in the 70s and 80s
the conservative coalition of the 70s
and 80s they accomplished stuff I don't
like but part of what they did in
progressives in the early 1900s and in
the 30s and conservatives in the 70s and
80s is that they didn't define their
movement so narrowly that over a 10
percent disagreement or a 20 percent
disagreement they cut people out from
Eve
being allowed to work together where
they agree so I'll give you some
examples there is a disagreement on the
left about whether nicolas maduro is a
good guy or not a good guy whether he's
been good or bad for Venezuela I think
that the evidence is strikingly clear
that Chavez Maduro have been a disaster
for Venezuela but it doesn't really
matter if people disagree with me on
that if we are united in the reality
that the United States should not
intervene the United States involvement
in regime change in Latin America has
been a disaster that we need to keep
John Bolton away from Venezuela we need
to keep Trump away from Venezuela I
every time I say this the comments 99%
are about how dare I
I am a shill for the centrist CIA right
or I don't even know what everything
because of being Jewish that's why I
have it's crazy we all agree the u.s.
shouldn't intervene in Venezuela so
let's focus on that right another
example can be I mean I don't know there
are so many of these when it comes to
the impeachment of Donald Trump
increasingly the left is united that
there have been impeach Abul offenses in
that at minimum an inquiry should start
and very often you will see a division
start because some people believe the
Moller report and others on the Left
seem to believe the bar letter if either
way you think
aside from quote collusion that there is
impeachable activity that donald trump
has engaged in why are we arguing about
collusion at this point it just doesn't
make any sense aside from the fact that
there were very few people on the Left
who actually were expecting evidence
that from personally colluded with Putin
I mean I don't know who was expecting
that I said in April of 2018 that I
wasn't so the real concern for me is
that I don't want the progressive
movement to draw lines so narrowly about
what is acceptable either via litmus
tests or whatever that people who could
get together and accomplish 80% of the
agenda on which they agree are going to
instead end up being enemies or at least
adversaries or at least talking past
each other and not working together
because of some 10 or 20% of the agenda
on which they disagree that's what I
think is the biggest problem with the
left right now